if you finished all the races and events  that Forza Motorsport 6 has to offer  then I've got some good news it looks  like a pretty big expansion full of  Porsches is on its way amazon like the  twenty dollar expansion with a release  date of march first the details have  since been removed but all games beta  managed to write them down before they  disappeared at the listing is legit then  we're getting 20 new Porsche models 48  new events and a new Raceway sounds like  a pretty nice complement to forza  horizon 2 sporty expansion ports of  developer turn 10 studios has yet to  confirm the expansion but it wouldn't be  the first major update to the game 4 to  6 started offering microtransactions  back in November and fallout 4 themed  cars have also been added if this pans  out you get to race those wasteland  vehicles against some classic german  sports cars in the meantime take a lap  with GameSpot for all the forts and news  you need  you